hey everyone i'm nate from hogging face
and today let's build a gradio app for
image classification using the tim
library
okay so to start off we're going to
create a new space called gradio demo
which i'll then clone locally
we'll first specify requirements using a
requirements.txt file and here we're
just going to specify tim and gradio
after that we're going to create an
application file called app.pi and here
i'll start specifying some imports
now since the model we're using was
trained on imagenet we're going to need
the labels for that so we can see the
class names when the app returns its
predictions so i'll just go grab that
and specify it here
now that's a url so we're going to make
a request to grab those labels from the
url to get them into a string list
after that we'll define the model in its
required transform which can be done by
calling some internal tim functions
and then we'll make sure that the pi
torch model is set to evaluation mode
since we'll be making predictions
now gradio apps work by defining a
prediction function so we'll do that
here i'm going to specify later that the
input is a pil image so that's what the
img variable is
we'll convert the image to rgb just in
case it has a transparent layers or
something
apply the transform and
add a batch dimension by calling
unsqueeze on the zeroth dimension of the
tensor now we can make our prediction
which we'll do by using
a torch.nograd
context manager and after that we'll be
able to get the probabilities by calling
softmax on the output
okay from there we can get the top five
predicted indices by calling torch.top k
and to finish off this function we're
going to need to take the indices that
we got and use them to look up the
actual label names using the labels
variable that we created at the
beginning now let's specify the gradient
interface itself remember we wanted pil
images as inputs so we have to specify
that and then the outputs here we can
just say label because we're just gonna
be returning labels
um we can launch that to start up the
app
now uh we'll just take this we're gonna
push it up we're not going to run it
we're just going to push it up and see
if it worked and you can see the build
logs as you go in case you need to
investigate any issues that come up or
anything like that
and sure enough i had an error in my
code so i'll go back and i'll just fix
that up and we'll push it up again
and there we go uh we can use an image
from our computer uh to see how it
worked here's one of me of me and my
fancy hug and face suit uh and look at
that it predicted suit which i wasn't
really expecting but it worked
so that's how you create a gradio app
for image classification using the tim
library if you found this video helpful
give it a like and consider subscribing
to our youtube channel for more content
like this you can also join our discord
server to connect with thousands of
other people interested in machine
learning thanks for watching until next
time bye
[Music]
you